- All right, y'all, these
next guests have performed
their music all over the world.
It's operatic pop, and
their sound is perfect
for the holiday season, it's beautiful.
Now performing, "Do You Hear What I Hear",
from the Museum of Dreamers
in the heart of Rome, Italy,
give it up for The Tenors.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(gentle music)
♪ Said the night wind to the little lamb ♪
♪ Do you see what I see ♪
♪ Way up in the sky, little lamb ♪
♪ A star, a star dancing in the night ♪
♪ With a tail as big as a kite ♪
♪ Do you see what I see ♪
♪ Said the little lamb
to the shepherd boy ♪
♪ Do you hear what I hear ♪
♪ Ringing through the sky, shepherd boy ♪
♪ A song, a song high above the trees ♪
♪ With a voice as big as the sea ♪
♪ Do you hear what I hear ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ With a voice as big as the sea ♪
♪ Hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm ♪
♪ Said the shepherd boy
to the mighty king ♪
♪ Do you know what I know ♪
♪ In your palace warm, mighty king ♪
♪ The Child, the Child
sleeping in the night ♪
♪ He will bring us goodness and light ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Do you know what I know ♪
♪ He will bring us goodness and light ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Goodness and light ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)
- All right, once more, give
it up for The Tenors, y'all.
Their new album, "Christmas
with The Tenors", is out now.
We'll be right back (indistinct).